I want to uh I want to deal with a
little bit of laundry now or just uh
some kind of behind the scenes stuff
really
um you know you guys we had an issue in
the past where uh Kai The Hitchhiker and
he's a famed
um
he uh you know he uh smashed smash
smashed somebody at an intersection with
a hammer
and he was that hammer baby you know
he's that freelance construction worker
and he um
he was like a national celebrity and he
and then he did
um murder he did a few murders and so
anyway uh that was a famed clip somebody
took my face and put it on his clip and
it made the rounds on social media and
it was you know funny and crazy I can't
believe that somebody made it
um but then at a certain point uh he
filed a lawsuit against me against me
and said that I was using his footage
and his
um
uh like name and like I don't know this
is using him
um and so we reached out to uh Morgan
and Morgan uh who's us who's a sponsor
of the podcast and uh my buddy Dan
Morgan is
um one of the Morgans over there and
uh and so they've been handling that
case for us and I thought it was over
with but apparently it's not uh we're
still getting stuff in the mail and um
and so that I want to check in right now
uh we have
is you know we have Arthur Petrosian
that's right Theo Hey Arthur how are you
today
good brother how are you I'm doing
pretty well man except uh you know I
keep getting hammered by this case man
this guy he's uh he's a resilient isn't
he
guys definitely persistent
um he's he's unfortunately been able to
dance around some of these procedural
issues in federal court keeping the case
alive
um the court still has not heard the
case on its merits so we're confident
that once they hear the case uh they're
ultimately going to dismiss it out and
how many like has he fought because yeah
I've got I keep getting paperwork and a
lot of handwritten stuff and how many
like how many
things has he filed at this point
multiple motions uh multiple amended
complaints
um you know it's fun to read to be
honest uh you know every time I come
into the office and I get a handwritten
note from Kai uh from his jail cell I
open it immediately I can't wait to read
it I actually have a document that he
filed with the court so this is an
official document that he filed in
federal court and this is all public
record so anytime you file a document in
federal court anybody that has an
account can go in and look at this so
um I I think this paragraph gives you a
glimpse of what this case is all about
and what he's been doing and if you'd
like I'll read it it's actually kind of
funny yeah I'd love to yeah let's get it
so so this is Kai and his moving papers
he says
plaintiff is writing this at 5 30 in the
morning in a sweltering hot cell in a
stone Building without air conditioning
that heats up during the day and holds
the heat throughout the night he's using
a floppy shank proof pen
he typed this at the law library but he
only gets five hours once a week if he's
granted extended access and his access
just ran out and then it goes on to say
even now plaintiff has to wake up at 3
30 in the morning get his work on this
opposition done before 11 A.M or else
the sweat soaked document would be
unacceptable for filing wow
defendant and that's you in Contra
distinction and these are his words as
begin has been making comedy videos in
an air-conditioned Studio making a show
in the most literal sense of slacking
off enjoying himself instead of filing a
responsive pleading
the court can see for themselves that
during the time in question defendant
was having the time of his life hmm
well so you know it's it's going nowhere
it's just things like this that he
continues to file again there the court
in order to provide him with due process
is kind of entertaining him at this
point okay
um but we strongly believe that within
the next 60 to 90 days when the court
actually hears the merits of the case
and actually reviews our motion to
dismiss that they're going to Grant it
so will we have to go to court do you
think
I would uh you don't have to but I will
definitely be there representing you
thank you first of all thank you very
much yeah absolutely I can't believe
you're here yeah I know I'm I'm really
grateful for you guys helping man
God I mean it's just so and so I guess
if somebody's in in jail they still have
the right they can still sue somebody
they can still even if they did murder
they can still you don't lose those
rights you know absolutely and this was
this is what this case is about and
that's why we've been kind of sitting on
the sidelines for about six to eight
months is because the federal court
wants to make sure that they provide Kai
is due process rights and they hear them
out uh again eventually this case gets
dismissed but for now we're going
through the motions and making sure that
the court hears them out wow
and do you guys get a lot of a lot of
cases like this
you know we don't handle a lot of cases
like this but we pride ourselves in in
fighting for the people and we consider
you a good friend Theo so uh We've we're
all hands on deck on this case we've got
multiple people pushing it uh we've got
experts lined up as well too just to
make sure that you're going to be
protected from every angle so you know
it's it's kind of an exciting case it
provides some comic value for us yeah
because it's it's different than a lot
of the other cases but yeah I almost
would I almost would well first of all
thank you guys so much man uh you know
uh Dan you know Dan Morgan's is a nice
guy and we have a lot of mutual friends
and and um and thank you guys too for
for supporting the podcast and I know
you guys mostly handle like personal
injury that type of stuff that's right
right but it would almost be crazy what
if we got to go do like a deposition or
something that would be wild wouldn't it
that would be wild it would be very
entertaining
um we would probably have to take it in
jail in Kai's cell probably I don't know
if he'll get extended hours to go to the
law library to who's that position from
there
that would be exciting exciting to do
yeah appreciate it man Thanks for liking
at least recognizing that uh this is
kind of entertaining along the way I'm
sure it is a little bit different than
normal
um yeah I mean he's definitely kind of a
notorious figure so
yeah
um well we're excited to back you up if
there's anything else you need you let
us know thank you hopefully hopefully I
will not but I appreciate that
you got it all right have a good day
brother
YouTube
wow so that's interesting you know
that's uh but you know I'm grateful that
you know if people if you that you don't
lose all your rights you know I mean
what a what a fortunate country where
you can
do a murder
and still
go and have rights
I mean that is you don't get some places
you don't even get that you know I'm
sure there's a lot of countries where
you don't get that
where if you do a murder that's it
you know they're like hey buddy you do
you do you do the murder
then you that's all you doing